[Music]
they're replacing the catwalkers
with woke talkers victoria's secret
cancelled its fashion show in 2019
amid criticism over lack of diversity in
the models
but it's now announced something way
better guys
a podcast series featuring diverse
spokeswomen telling their stories
because if your underwear can't preach
at you they will
turns out victoria victoria's secret was
being afraid of the far
left the spokeswoman will include indian
actress
priyanka chopra jonas is that married to
a jonas brother
soccer player slash lgbt advocate megan
rappano and transgender brazilian model
valentina sampio
unlike me none of the women will be
posing in lingerie
when the brand chief executive martin
waters was asked about the brand's
angels returning he said simply right
now i don't see it as being
culturally relevant then he ran away and
hid under a rock
so to recap this is what victoria's
secret used to be
[Applause]
and this is how it's going to be from
now on
it's true and i'm talking about the
thematic nature of it
cat you know what kills me about this
they're
playing woke for a paycheck
from they're being paid cynically by a
company they would normally
hate but they realize that i could like
if they disapprove of victoria's secret
why would they
offer to do this podcast right
victoria's secret's biggest problem was
never like all the super hot ladies
like they have been so many like exposes
you know connections to epstein's people
and all this stuff they're like i got it
awoke podcast that we sponsor
problem solved and i the fashion show
who cares i never watched it because i
could you know
i wanted to have someone come over and
point and laugh at my body
but um some people did and they enjoyed
that
nobody's gonna listen to this podcast no
no there's already too many podcasts
we don't need any more podcasts and
underwear doesn't need
a podcast no more panties less podcasts
that's what dad used to say hey so jimmy
this is exactly how virtue signaling
works you hear you have a company
plagued by
legitimately bad press being connected
to jeffrey epstein who was doing
something with the
the president of the company so what do
you do you throw your whole brand
under the bus to embrace this new shield
of wokism
and it and it's from so now it's like
beautiful models
that's sexist lingerie is patriarchy
let's do this let's find the people that
on twitter are like really interesting
yeah i like the title of the podcast
though i believe it's called chapter
eleven nicely
no one is no one is listening to this
yeah every woke initiative is a
shakedown what is the always
the end result we're gonna do this
virtuous thing and by the way someone is
taking a pile of money from us
what is critical race theory what is any
of these lecture series the corporation
gets credit and somebody else shows up
and gets 48 000
to give a speech no one wants to listen
to right this is what everybody needs to
know
okay there's nothing wrong with having
something people like
do what you're good at you know what it
reminds me of like when mcdonald's
started to make healthy food right
nobody goes to mcdonald's to eat healthy
it's like hiring a hooker to snuggle you
know what i mean that's not why you're
there
stick with your current job can you
stick with your current job next worker
yeah exactly
she got 48 thousand dollars for that but
no it is it is absurd
and i hate that they're doing this
because victoria's secret what were they
in the market of you know lingerie sex
attraction
there was nothing less attractive than
activism yeah that's absolutely the last
thing
you want to hear when the the sexy sack
comes on so what do you think of climate
change
i think it's changing the song and
getting out of here yeah yeah i i only
have sex while watching michael moore
documentary
it makes your man feel better about his
body
um what do you what is your thought as
a vibrant lovely woman i have to stay
within my boundaries so i don't end up
in human resources
again so number one this company started
going
down the tubes because they overlooked
the bralette
and sports bra trend i had no idea so
they overlooked overlook
flat-chested women doesn't everyone
yep so that's why they're going down the
tubes and
secondly i used to cover this fashion
show
and i have been backstage with these
women
all this company needed to do to
be inclusive with all women is to show
what these women
look like before they've dieted before
the fashion show
and photograph them in broad daylight
because they all have cellulite
they're skinny but they've got weird big
faces like one like one eye
like one eye is bigger than another one
and they've got
big horse mouths when you get up close
you are arousing me
yeah and like one and they all are in
underwires because one boob's pointing
that way and one's pointing that way
i said completely imperfect okay
we're talking about my dream woman
i always wanted to date a salvador dali
painting
you know um robbie is there anything
that hasn't been said in this segment
that you can add to it
you know my grandparents are watching
currently so i think i'll just sit this
conversation
oh come on um the podcast
is going to be a terrible idea i think
we said that why does everything
why does every company have to have a
viewpoint
at all exactly just sell a product like
if i wanted to hear a viewpoint i would
go to like a like a magazine or a think
tank or something
my organization has viewpoints this
channel has viewpoints we have
viewpoints but we don't but we're also
not trying to sell underwear why don't
i try i have viewpoints i should start
selling underwear
well actually probably fox nation has
boxers right
they want my underwear hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page
and catch our hottest interviews and
most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else